on one of my mom or naive and young days
several years ago I decided to take a
hike it was a glorious spring day and
some friends of and I were camping and I
decided to set off from our campsite and
attempt to hike to a particular Lake
nestled high between two gorgeous
mountains I needed to clear my head so I
decided to walk alone mistake number one
I also decided to travel light just add
a pact with maybe a band-aid inside no
extra layers no map mistakes two three
and four I brought along one bottle of
water for a 15-mile hike big mistake
number five I had a pretty good idea
where I was heading and the trail was
well blazedd but as I hiked miles up and
up and up that mountain path my water
supply was dwindling fast I was thirsty
and my focus quickly narrowed to one
thing running water must find running
water to refill my bottle so i can keep
walking or i'll have to turn around
suddenly my peaceful hike in the woods
to think and ponder and soak in God's
majestic beauty turned stressful and
actually could have been quite dangerous
you're all familiar with the wilderness
I know you are whether you've traveled
there by your own wandering or been
pushed there by circumstances out of
your control you are familiar with the
contours of the wilderness wild
unpredictable unmanageable mysterious
invigorating scary harsh the wilderness
is the very place where we meet John the
Baptist this morning and many are
meeting him here people are flocking to
the wilderness to meet John and be
baptized by him this means leaving home
and comfort and trekking out into the
desert it's easy to get lost in the
desert and water is scarce and the
environment is unforgiving but our
hunger for God drives us to the edge of
our comfort zone and then even further
our thirst for God leads us to a
vulnerable walk along an uncertain path
sometimes it takes going to the
wilderness to be able to listen and see
more clearly it's loud here in the city
sometimes even here in church it's
bright with artificial light and the
stars are hidden from us in the
wilderness can be a place of clarity
then again the wilderness is not a place
most of us desire to go or at least stay
for very long the wilderness of mental
illness or physical pain the wilderness
of isolation or grief these are the
landscapes in which we feel most
particularly alone when we run out of
our own resources and find ourselves
parched yet this is the very place where
Christ meets us John the Baptist assures
us in the wilderness that Christ is not
far off he is coming and in the meantime
John is showing us how to find scarce
water in the desert pointing away toward
hope when the landscape seems hopeless
we are turning into this second week of
Advent are you in the wilderness yet
Fred need nura writes the holy way of
Advent that cross toting fools tread
leads not out of the wilderness but ever
deeper into it none of us will escape
the wilderness anyway our whole life
happens within its wordless void on its
arid slopes that drain the life from us
as we wander in circles learning the
same lessons over and over there in the
wilderness as we wander in those circles
John the Baptist call
out to us to reflect to confess to
repent reflect on the wilderness in
which we find ourselves this Advent
confess how we wrongly assumed we could
travel with just a little bit of water
and our own self sufficiency would feel
less the rest of the way repent because
we set out alone and now we see we just
might need that holy company that is
always with us I don't know about you
but I can't seem to remember what I
learned in the wilderness sure I learned
my lesson but amnesia sets in about two
minutes later and I find myself
wandering around the wilderness again
thirsty maybe life's goal shouldn't be
to avoid the wilderness those hard times
those unforgiving landscapes but instead
practice living Christ sway in the
wilderness in his own wilderness moments
Christ faced temptation with strength
and faith even after fasting for 40 days
and nights and facing exhaustion he
forgave those who hurt him even during
the wilderness of his crucifixion he
found quiet places to pray when he could
have been doing 18 other things could
this be how we are called to prepare the
way of the Lord to face temptation with
faith to forgive others as we have been
forgiven to find quiet places to pray
look around your wilderness what would
it mean to believe that Christ is coming
to your wilderness to transform it to
transform you Isaiah believed it and his
prophecy declares it every Valley shall
be lifted up every mountain and Hill be
made low uneven ground shall become
level and the rough places a plane then
the glory of the Lord shall be revealed
the glory of the Lord
shall be revealed to the ones in the
hospital this morning to those who are
persecuted throughout the world to you
and to me John is pointing to Jesus that
Jesus who is coming ready or not John is
helping to prepare the way of the Lord
and this Advent we are called to do the
same but with humility feeney Perkins
reminds us we do not build the highway
and then wait for God to come God has
already drawn near to us I had walked
five miles from my campsite I had less
than half of my water left I knew that
if I continued walking I would run the
risk of going dry especially if I happen
to get lost I resigned myself to the
reality of a failed hike I would never
see that beautiful hidden mountain lake
at least not today before I turned
around to hike back to camp i sat down
for a moment to rest on a rock only then
and only then could i faintly hear the
rush of a stream there somewhere just
ahead I could take huge gulps of
ice-cold water and refill my bottle and
continue the long walk this is life in
the wilderness we're never as prepared
as we could be sometimes we walk alone
very much alone and we rely on our own
resources as long as we can but at the
very moment when I finally realized how
unprepared i was admitted it my own
resources were running dry I learned
that God prepares a way for us in the
wilderness this is life in the
wilderness when our hunger for success
finally yields to our deeper hunger for
God when our thirst for self-sufficiency
yields finally to our deeper thirst for
peace at the very moment we are about to
turn around and walk the other way God
provides streams of
living water just up ahead rivers of
grace in the desert enough living water
to sustain us in the wilderness as you
walk through these next advent days
until we gather here again try to walk
Christ's way this Advent seeking quiet
places to pray especially when you don't
think you have time forgiving others and
yourselves as Christ has forgiven
resisting the temptation to run out of
the wilderness Christ is coming to meet
you here in the wilderness walk his way
and you will be sustained amen